welcome to the presentation on
multiplying decimals let's get started
so I think you'll find out that
multiplying decimals is not a lot more
difficult than just multiplying regular
numbers and I'll show you in a problem
so let's say let me pick some random
numbers let's say I had 7,000 518
actually let's make that 75 point one
eight clearly you can tell I'm doing
this on the fly seventy five point one
eight times zero point nine seven so
first you look at this problem like oh
boy that's tough these decimals I don't
I don't even know how to approach it
well this is what you do you ignore the
decimals when you start the problem and
you pretend like it's just a regular
multiplication problem and if you ignore
the decimals and you would be like I
said at the beginning seven thousand
five hundred eighteen on top and 97 on
the bottom and if that does make sense
let me just show you I'm just going to
ignore the decimals and do this like a
normal multiplication problem so normal
multiplication I'd start at the ones
place right here and say seven times
eight
well seven times eight is fifty-six
carry the five seven times one is seven
plus the five is twelve two down here
carry the one seven times five is
thirty-five plus the one is thirty six
the six here carry the three and then
seven times seven is forty-nine plus two
is 52 so just put 52 here so just like
normal multiplication we just took the
ones place right here the sevens it's
actually not the ones but we're ignoring
ignoring the decimal so if there were no
decimal this would be the ones place and
we're multiplying it by the top number
seven times seven thousand five hundred
and eighteen is equal to fifty two
thousand six hundred twenty-six
I like regular multiplication we do the
tens place and once again this isn't
really the tens place but if you ignore
the decimals it would be and let's cross
all this stuff out since we're not using
it nine times eight seventy-two carry
the seven nine times one is nine plus
seven is
sixteen carry the 1 9 times 5 is 45 this
is good practice for me do haven't done
my multiplication times multiplication
tables in the long time 9 times 5 is 45
plus 1 is 46 carry the 4 9 times 7 is 63
plus 4 is 67 now we add so you're
probably thinking boy
what does decimals have to do with this
at all I'm just doing a regular
multiplication problem and I'll show you
it actually the decimals only come in
right at the very end so what I do is
now I just add like I do a regular level
for multiplication problem
so I say 6 plus 0 is 6 2 plus 2 is 4 6
plus 6 is 12 carry the 1 1 plus 2 plus 6
is 9 5 plus 7 is 12 carry the 1 1 plus 7
1 plus 6 is 7 ok so now here's where the
decimals come into place and your I
think you're going to be shocked by how
straightforward this is what I do is I
go back to the original problem and now
I actually pay attention to the decimals
and I say how many total numbers are
behind the decimal point
well there's one number behind the
decimal point two numbers behind the
decimal point three numbers behind the
decimal point four numbers behind the
decimal point one two three four so
there are four numbers behind the
decimal point in the problem I did then
I just count here 1 2 3 4 the answer
will also have 4 numbers behind the
decimal point
and that's the answer 72 point nine two
four six now let me ask you a question
if I had a 0 here would that count as an
extra number behind the decimal point
well it only would have been if you
actually use the 0 in the multiplication
and maybe that confuses you what I would
recommend if you have any trailing zeros
with a decimal like this you actually
should just ignore those zeros and then
do the
just the way I did it and when remember
that's only four trailing zeros if you
had if this was the bottom number then
that zero would matter because it's not
a trailing zero it actually adds it's
actually part of the number let's do a
couple more examples and I think that'll
make sense so let's say I had five I'm
going to a simpler example Aerith
matically but I think it'll help you
with some principles if I set five point
one zero times 1.09 so there's two
things we could do we could just
multiply it the way it is actually let's
do it both ways and I'll show you you
have to you get the same answer whether
or not you ignore that zero so in the
first case let's not ignore the zero
let's pretend like that zero is let's
use that dear even though that trailing
zero in the decimal five point one zero
is the same thing as five point one but
let's use it nine times zero is zero 9
times 1 is 9 9 times 5 is 45 and in the
zeros place you put a 0 and then 0 times
everything is 0 right 0 times 0 0 times
1 0 times 5 but 2 zeroes here and then 1
times 0 is 0 1 times 1 is 1 and 1 times
5 is 5 and now we add it all 0 9 5 5 5
and like we did before we just count the
decimals 1 2 3 4 so 1 2 3 4 so the
decimal will go here right so we got
five point five five nine zero is the
answer now what if we did like I was
recommending we actually ignore this 0
so I say and I can actually rewrite it
as 1.09 times five point one because you
know in multiplication order doesn't
matter
eight times B is the same thing as B
times a 2 times 3 is the same thing as 3
times 2 so 1.09 times 5.1 is the same
thing as five point one times 1.09 so
let's just multiply this out and notice
these are the same numbers all I did is
I take took off it took zero off so
first I just ignore the decimals I say 1
times 9 is 9
I'm 1 times 0 is 0 1 times 1 is 1 put a
0 here 5 times 9 is 45 carry the 4 5
times 0 is 0 plus 4 is 4 5 times 1 is 5
now I add 9 5 5 5 and I say ok how many
now I'm at the point that I can actually
pay attention to the decimal point so I
say how many point how many numbers are
behind the decimals well there's 1 2 3
so I go 1 2 3 put the decimal point
right here notice I got the same exact
answer the only difference is that this
one had a trailing zero which is really
doesn't make a number any different I
could add 100 zeros here and the number
is really not a different number this is
just well what if you were a computer
programmer I guess this could become a
statistician of some kind this could be
an important number but ignore what I
just said and but for for your purposes
these trailing zeros mean nothing right
same way a leading zero actually
wouldn't mean nothing no one ever does
that let me do well let me see how much
time I am have two more minutes let me
do one more problem just to maybe hit
the point home but really I just want to
you know this is really no different
than level level up for multiplication
and at the end you just have to count
the numbers behind the decimal point so
5 times 5 is 25 whoops
25 I'm already getting it messy carry
the 2 5 times 7 is 35 plus 2 is 37 bring
down the 7 carry the 3 5 times 0 is 0
plus 3 so it's 375 ignore that blob I'm
sorry for being so messy then you put a
0 1 times 5 is 5 1 times 7 is 7 and
ignore that and now we add we say 5 plus
0 is 5 7 plus 5 is 12 1 plus 3 plus 7 is
11 so we got our answer now I just have
to count the decimals so here we have 1
two three four five numbers behind the
decimal points behind our answer we only
have four digits so how can we get five
numbers behind the decimal point well we
start here we say one two three four and
we need one more number behind the
decimal point so we add a zero here and
then we put the decimal point see what I
just did we had to have five numbers
behind the decimal point
so we only had four numbers in the
answer so I added a leading zero and
then put the decimal point and now we
have five numbers behind the decimal
point and I've shown you a very
mechanical way of doing this hopefully
in the future I can give you a seminar
and actually why this method of counting
the numbers behind the decimal points
actually works but I think you are ready
to try some problems the multiplying
decimals have fun